thank you
[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys where today
we have Jason Cheney in the seat James
thank you so much Anthony welcome thank
you so much Anthony welcome Jason we
like it when Jason Cheney's here yeah we
do dude everybody likes it man we always
get tons of comments about bringing them
back and [ __ ] I just want to say that um
you guys are really nice stop saying
that we are nice I don't I know we're
not nah that's that's Wong Fu they're
the nice guys can I say can I'm gonna
tell you guys something are you gonna
choke on it
I'm gonna tell you guys something all
right this is um secret yeah okay how'd
you know it seem like you're preparing
for a secret okay this is the secret you
got allergies is that some people
help you and some people show you love
but then they have a certain type of
energy towards you they go like yeah but
I'm I'm showing you love like know that
know that I'm showing you love like like
I I want to cash in on this later cash
in on this later okay or not I'm helping
you yeah but not even casual in the day
like I'm helping you like just know that
I'm helping you like you get that energy
that's weird and I never felt that with
David so him and you guys I never felt
that so it's just love that's so nice
and I've when people help me in anything
in stand up or whatever the thing is
sometimes they'll be like you know
um you just feel that energy like how
you feel like we're helping you or David
helping you how do you mean which is
really nice that you should like we just
want to hang out
what like we just want to hang out or
put me on um let me be here like on and
just kidding dude it's super cool but
yeah but I just want I don't know why I
started to say that but it was very nice
of you that's really nice that's very
nice yeah that's that's what you are
other people that you're talking you
know who it is man oh no I have that kid
[Laughter]
but yeah but you can't say at all that's
dope but what was the thing that what
was it the thing you were just about to
say who are the people that like you
know that they expect something from you
when they're being nice like who what
but we all know who those people are in
our lives we all know who they are I
don't know who they are in your life
yeah who is it who is it who is it first
last name this is what I'm talking about
I come here with some positivity
and y'all come here trying to pry my
[ __ ] open it
dude Bart was pre-med he knows how to
look down here for the fans we're the
voice of the fans you know we're genuine
friends
who's the [ __ ] that are trying
to use you yeah but this is what I'm
talking about the oh my hands should
touch your [ __ ] let's get them dude
red thing on it says record nobody
watches this show except for us okay
just tell us so it's always really nice
you know that um yeah in entertainment
just a good time so give us an example
of how people
do that to you what's the last time yeah
just remember I'm [ __ ] helping you
they don't say it but you know it's just
an energy like they like as they do it
that you don't feel like oh it's just so
it's like here's your Starbucks order
you remember who gave it to you
that's what Joe did you this morning why
are you looking at me so intently like
that yeah but uh
so it's just uh are you sure David's in
the same category
yeah yeah all right but yeah because
sometimes you know wide spectrum yeah I
never felt that yeah I never felt that
it was really cool best time David hated
you you'd know off the Jump dude David
makes no effort to make friends yeah if
you don't like you he won't even funny
things really yeah he's pretty straight
up like that oh wow which is cool yeah
it is cool yeah because you know what
you're dealing with a Korean man but
sometimes I'm like um that's why
sometimes I'm like because I don't know
him like you guys know him and that's
why uh when he sometimes is supportive
like you but yeah you guys are pretty
supportive but David sometimes when he
says stuff is like like you said because
he's so critical so it's nice that yeah
is that like that father thing again
it's like oh he never loved me but when
he says hey you wanna
go to the park you know or whatever and
you go oh that's nice
do you mean like this small love has
anybody ever told you that when you like
tell stories sometimes you like cut out
all the important words
hey man if you get it you get them if
you know you know if you know you know
man that's real trust that's right I
don't know I like no it's like playing
Mad Libs you know you're just fill in
the blank yeah but you like it yeah no
I'm enjoying it it's like a puzzle yes
it's like a puzzle that's why you're so
mysterious but like a fun puzzle
anything new happen since the last time
we saw you
yeah so I I it was really nice I had
just kidding news on it it was uh when I
went to Sacramento actually a couple
times people will be like hey I saw you
on just kidding news oh cool and I go
thank you that's so nice that makes me
so happy because most of them are Asian
so you're stealing our fans yes and then
they go like this but where's
Bard and everybody and Joe and the team
and David so my name is Anthony yeah
Anthony I like how people think we all
move as one unit everywhere we go we
should start because a lot of people
always ask that where's where's spark
yeah where's where's where's everybody
they're always that like I was in
[ __ ] San Jose I like a powerlifting
me right oh boy where's Joe I'm like
this is a power lifting me why would he
be here
I'm like that's not that's not even his
hobby it doesn't make any sense yeah at
least make sense yeah make some [ __ ]
sense yeah it's like you know if I'm not
like a [ __ ] cat convention they saw
him at the strip club and they're like
where's Joe that makes sense you know
yeah if I'm at the shooting range or
[ __ ] some truck festival or some [ __ ]
yeah all right kenja's rehearsal that's
true but then I would be like why should
bark be here that's right I don't got
the skill he hates the kid just that's
right I left him just don't get that
that's right we're all fans of the King
James dude are you a fan of the Kansas
Jason Cheney okay I'm gonna tell you
another secret okay perfect this is
great it's like no
that secret was a little underwhelming
that's [ __ ] nice [ __ ] I don't
hear that [ __ ] but that's some real [ __ ]
though it's from my heart you know thank
you thank you yeah that's all my heart
what's the second secret the second
secret is that um
ah
weather
you changed your
what's the second
the second secret thing is that I'm not
I don't know a lot of music I don't know
a lot about they ever heard the Kinder's
music yeah he has no ideas what kinjaz
is he's being polite and he's like it
can just sucks no I don't know that's
why I'm saying I don't know a lot about
sometimes I don't even know a lot about
stand up but you listen to Jazz and and
Country I don't know the name I don't
know the album name they're not that
group of friends that when we're putting
you up we expect something in return
like you know
he didn't know what to picture he didn't
know if it was [ __ ] three guys or
whatever there's 40 people
it's a small state but I heard of the
name is the thing I know of it yeah it's
not a big deal I just said I know the
name man hey
kinjaz really they hate when people
don't know them so yeah it's good you
said something that's a new one we're
gonna run with it for no reason but
that's a new one
but sometimes I just you know sometimes
I'm like man do I because I don't know
because I'm not
more importantly it's really cool that
you have new fans from JK that are
showing up to your show oh yeah yeah I
saw you tagging that I don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about dude yeah
what do they say when they come up to
you what are you saying say oh I saw you
on just kidding news that's sick what do
you say them to them I said that's so
cool that's nice thank you and that's so
nice that it would have me I say that
and then they're gonna wear the same
thing with David yeah yeah and then
they'll be like man I thought
um maybe they will come
this one time I said that oh yeah that's
so nice yeah but not all all of them but
one time they said it I was like oh yeah
did that make you feel like you were
number two it's okay yeah it's okay yeah
because it is nice already that they
came to the show yeah because before we
we turned the cameras on you were
telling me that
um it wasn't so nice back then and now
it's nice yeah whatever it is that's why
like that was my reference it's from
nobody would come and see my shows and
now you have fans that actually follow
you for you exactly so then before it
was just you know people that
um are gonna go to The Comedy Club
anyways and it doesn't matter which
doesn't matter what you say so you just
gotta make them laugh there's actually a
lot of people that watched your episodes
here because they followed you here too
oh that's so nice you brought some fans
yeah a ton you brought some of your own
fans too yeah but yeah but it's all nice
you're doing a lot of a lot more shows
now yeah he's got three tonight three
tonight right back wow yeah but always
in I feel like in LA is just you're
doing showcase Bots but Comics leave LA
and New York to go headline and make
money but when we come back we're just
doing showcase spots and being the scene
and stuff yeah yeah when you do three
tonight is it at the same club or you
gotta drive no different Club how do you
make it on time you just make it on time
I'm really grateful that I get to do
that they're just different slots right
like it's like six o'clock here seven
o'clock there or whatever ten o'clock
but starting out there's no way that you
could do that because you have to be you
know like who the [ __ ] are you not that
I'm anybody now it's just that in the
beginning is even harder to do even more
than once you're somebody yeah you are
somebody I like your style of Comedy
though no thanks yeah because you're not
like you're not like you're not hacky I
try not to be yeah and you I like like
the gun bit though that we were watching
I was like oh that's a different take I
just want to say the stuff that's in my
heart I always want to just say the
stuff that's in my heart but in the
beginning of people shame me like I'm
sure any any and anything you like
because if you do too much Asian jokes
you go oh he's just doing too much Asian
jokes so for longest time I didn't do
Asian jokes and people go oh but he's
not doing Asian jokes so I just do a
little bit of a kitchen job
it's hard to please everyone yeah
you're being too animated
no I was and then and then so I just
started talking like this to but that
work that made me work on another muscle
to get my jokes better or whatever and
then people go oh he's not even fun to
watch because he just stands there so
then you go you know you just find what
so now I just want to say it's time to
kind of chisel yeah who you are right
yeah we're gonna get extremely off the
Record real quick I'll do it that's what
this is right I always like your thing
but only if you're willing to and
comfortable sharing it's amazing uh
behind the joke type of like bit that
you can share here whether it's like a
bit that you're working on or like
inspiration for this very popular joke
came from this story anything that you
could share
um well I think mostly the the thing
with my thing is that I always are very
conflicted all the time and all the time
because I I always want to see both
sides like on on both things like
earlier you're like well but [ __ ] that
guy
on another episode it doesn't sound like
me at all I was like for sure [ __ ] that
guy
but but then also I'm like oh I wanted
to maybe he's a sad too or whatever oh
yeah but I always do but that's not
child molester that child yeah
regular teacher
you were defending the child molester
we're trying to catch you yeah yeah I
wasn't yeah you just you
oh is that the one where you're talking
about Taliban yeah no no it was the ball
no no it was the it was the laxative guy
yeah this is out of context is just like
wow it's good it's good it's good you
think not enough Comics do that like
they don't try to see both or like no
not that I just because I think that's
just who you are I have like I always
thought that old man that sucks because
when you have a really extreme thing
it's always fun or it's nice to have
somebody's like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but
in my heart I'm always like I always
wanted to dissect it dissect it yeah but
then not most people are not like that I
like that a lot of your style though you
you get people to go yeah [ __ ] that and
then you just immediately turn on them
to make them go oh wait no that really
yeah I don't know anymore because that's
how I feel yeah but I don't know which
side I'm so that's already built in
comedy or not that's just your life yeah
yeah and that's how you're seeing the
topic and stuff seeing the topic or
anything but sometimes it sucks because
a lot of things like work or life you
like you have to make decision yeah or
else you're not moving forward you have
to make a decision but a lot of the
times I don't
um I don't make a decision decision
right away can we um you know maybe
pressure you into either an old bit that
you've retired or something you're
working on now that shows a little bit
of that mentality
um or maybe the one that I have about
guns is that I'm not
or super against it but I'm also not for
it
but the thing is that I have some
but the thing is I don't want them
I have some guns what but you don't want
them I don't want them I don't want
anybody there
but everybody else got them that's why I
got 19 of them you got 19 guns I got
nine of them oh that's a lot I mean that
is a lot still yeah holy [ __ ] which ones
are do you have perfect you got 19 like
he's got less he's got more than you no
for sure
how many of which ones you have I have
like some Glocks and cigs and two AR
pistols yeah how many Glocks you have
three three which ones are they they're
Glock 19 one of my face two Glock 19 and
then 143 I got two look my teeth too
because they're so nice and then they're
like positional clocks it's like one has
to be in the kitchen you know and
another one has you want to properly
defend your house properly defend your
house you need them to be in different
places yeah yeah because if the robber
comes in you can't just be like oh let
me get to the kids let me go to the
living room to get my gun yeah yeah you
can't be like time out time out I gotta
go to the kitchen yeah
so just different but the thing is it's
conflicting because I don't want it I
don't want other people to have it
either
but um but they have it so you have to
have it well I don't have to have it but
it's just nice to have it it's a nice
piece of mind yeah and it's also fun
because sometimes you go at the shooting
range and you just focus on that thing
because you want to uh be safe and then
um you know and then
have a good time
where the government wants everyone to
turn in their guns yeah BuyBacks
impossible yeah are you gonna turn in
your guns nah
so they show up at your house when you
go I don't have them I lost them I go um
if you can find them you can have them
[Laughter]
they they
found it oh they take four uh no I don't
know well I don't know do you guys all
have them so on both sides I don't know
what I am though is the thing you don't
have them I don't have guns I do I kind
of want a gun but I also don't want a
gun but I almost maybe should I get a
gun because everybody has a gun I think
you guys are in the same same boat he's
got nine but how many of you his his
boat has nine guns my boat's gunless I
want a gun but I also don't want a gun
at the same time so I get what you mean
because it is scary you are a gun
practically yeah that's what I'm saying
but if a gun shot me in the face
he can't [ __ ] do a [ __ ] sideways
I wish we could live in a world without
guns and I wish we don't have how many
guns you have I don't even McDonald's
yeah but I wish we don't have to have
guns but if you're allowed to have it
but guns exist so I need to have them
I'm in the Boy Scout kayak right where
you can see everything you're in like
the USS Michigan or whatever the [ __ ]
that's how many guns you already have
this is a different Battleship you're in
a battleship we're in a different boat
you know what I mean because it might
have similar sentiment yeah but when
when sense sentiment don't mean nothing
when you got the battleship and I'm in a
canoe no I don't see like that I see it
as you could be a virgin or a [ __ ] but
they're both the same amount of horny
interesting right because the Virgin is
horny as [ __ ] is that from the Bible the
version the Virgin might be hornier than
the [ __ ] that's true because they're so
frustrated you know it's just I pulled
the trigger on getting guns a lot more
times yeah but I'm not so did Jason but
it doesn't make me want to love guns
more that sounds conditional but I'll
take it you know what I mean it's just I
just did it more I just went to the
store more time because for someone
that's like not really quarter quarter
gun enthusiasts having nine guns is a
lot of guns
I think that I want to get it yeah I get
you I get you how'd it turn into nine
yeah well you get one and these are
fully automatic assault rifles by the
way we're talking about it what's your
what's your favorite gun that you have
whichever one that fires correctly
that's pretty cool no but I but I asked
my friend why don't you have one because
he's like well if I have one I gotta
accept that I'm willing to kill somebody
and he hasn't accepted that yeah I never
thought that I was like oh [ __ ] I'm a
bad person but then I'm like what he
just bought it without thinking about
shootings that's like you and fighting
dude I know but but I don't want my wife
to die if it's either them or me and my
wife my wife
and I don't want it to be my wife
because you're thinking about some guy
coming in and having his way with your
wife and killing both of you and you're
just like I ain't gonna let that happen
and and oh and this is another thought
is that like I feel like people who are
extremely against it not all but some
people who are extremely against it they
never been around violence or things
like that that'd be so true every single
time I've had this discussion with
someone right that is against it I give
them scenarios and they go that will
never happen yeah but it happens all the
time do you not understand that
robberies murders kidnappings grapes all
these things happen all the [ __ ] time
right now it happens [ __ ] Welch's
grapes happens every day that's why you
learn martial arts and it's like dude
you are so stupid like you've never been
through a violent situation you're just
[ __ ] making [ __ ] up you're making it
up yeah but that's why I feel the yeah
they're like that's why you learn
martial arts that's why you buy a bat
okay
you it's like dude you guys never been
through any [ __ ] crime yeah or in the
[ __ ] Jiu Jitsu is not gonna do [ __ ]
if a mountain lion climbs in her
backyard not when I go like this
[ __ ] watch your mouth I'm right
here you're killing my business dude no
dude it will save you against a mountain
lion mountain Lionheart Jiu Jitsu dude
it's stupid see that's what he [ __ ] up
you should have learned kickboxing oh
see you should have called it Mountain
Lionheart jab a [ __ ] line in the face
nah dude you get your [ __ ] eaten you
know and you're like damn I spent all
this time yeah because I'm disarming the
mountain lion
tap eventually right yeah I'll tap on a
mountain lion
foreign